it all started with Donald Trump being
like an agent of Russia you know and now
literally the thing that they're getting
him on is that he inflated the price of
his condo like that's how far it's
Fallen by the way Bill Clinton on
Epstein's jet 20 times never reported
multiple times some without his secret
service the biggest human trafficker
that we know of he's on a plane about no
one cares Donald Trump they're like well
you know that that's not worth what he
said it was right he said it had eight
bathrooms it has six it has a powder
room that's a powder room it's not a
full bathroom that's not a full bathroom
it's a powder room it's psyonic that's
not an Eden kitchen what are you nuts
you see he said it was Eden what about
the guy that was on the human
traffickers plate well he's been honest
about his assets that's what I care
about I care about somebody honest about
their assets if you say it's a fifth
bedroom but it's set up as an office and
it doesn't have a window it's not a
bedroom you go what